angular a typescript-based framework for
building user interfaces
it was developed at google and released
in 2016 as the sequel to angularjs
as an angular developer you hit the
ground running with its extremely
powerful cli tool
when you generate your initial
application it comes pre-configured with
routing
a testing framework and your favorite
style preprocessor in addition
the magic ng add command can turn your
app into a progressive web app
add server-side rendering firebase
support and do a whole bunch of other
cool stuff
but at its core angular is just a
component-based ui library i can create
a component with the cli
and if we go into its typescript file
you'll notice the component decorator
which makes this typescript class a
component any properties on this class
are considered reactive state
and when their values change the
component will re-render the ui
for example we can bind the property to
html using double braces in the template
from there we can add a button that
increments this value every time it's
clicked
we add the event name on the left side
in parentheses then an expression
on the right side in this case it points
to a method in our class
each time the button is clicked it calls
the method which changes the state
and re-renders the ui angular also has a
variety of directives for building
complex templates
use ngf to handle conditional logic or
if you have an iterable value
use ng4 to loop over it but where
angular really excels is handling
complexity and one of its primary tools
for doing so is called dependency
injection
when your app grows to hundreds of
components you'll likely need a way to
share data and functionality between
them we can take our component logic
here and extract it into a service which
can be treated as a global singleton
throughout the application
now any component that wants to use this
state or logic can simply add this class
to its constructor
the end result is a simple and reliable
way to compose complex applications
as a developer you can always count on a
consistent experience between projects
and minimal decision fatigue this has
been angular in 100 seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this make sure to like and
subscribe and check out a ton of
advanced angular content on fireship io
thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one